the World Cup and guitar begins with a
thumping England Victory and more
predictable rounds about politics can we
please for the love of God just focus on
the football my All-Star starting lineup
features Peter Chilton Mark laurenson
and Kevin Peterson
plus I speak what I want and I'm
bulletproof Cristiano Ronaldo definitely
responds to the Fallout from our
interview as you write to speak out or
debate that with the capacity crowd and
tonight's Morgan Arena
no virtually signaling allowed
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening Phil London welcome to
Piers Morgan and sensor the World Cup is
finally underway the biggest event in
World sport The Greatest Show on Earth
and if you look very closely really
we're very very closely you might even
see a bit of football politics has
predictably overshadowed sport in the
first 24 hours the tournament the
England players today the best possible
response to all the virtue signaling
they got on with the game and got on
with it very well
acquire
[Applause]
who gets it down to Saka
looking for Sterling
and sucker keeps on going himself oh why
wouldn't he there's the second there's
the next England well all the build up
to that thumping win against Iran it's
dominated by the fa's humiliating u-turn
on plans for Captain Harry Kane to wear
a rainbow armband the plan protest
against qatar's non-existent gay rights
quickly buckled under threats of yellow
cards and possible suspensions Wales
also back down to England players did
take the knee but there was no gesture
from England in support of the thousands
of Iranians risking their life to demand
women's rights at home and that's my
problem with all this virtue signaling
once you start where do you stop and if
you're gonna do it then do it
the BBC has made their own decisions
about this we've left Alex Scott a
pundit to where the rainbow Ironbound on
air today good for her but last night
after the BBC totally snubbed the
opening ceremony Gary lineker said this
from accusations of corruption in the
bidding process to the treatment of
Migrant workers who built the stadiums
where many lost their lives
homosexuality is illegal here
women's rights and freedom of expression
are in the spotlight
but where's the consistency Britain's
broadcasters had no problem showing the
massive opening ceremony the Russia
World Cup for example attended by
murderous Putin himself nor did the BBC
filmer need to censor the opening
ceremony the Beijing Winter Olympics
just nine months ago even as China is
accused of a genocide against a weaker
Muslims for an example of real courage
and a protest that might actually make a
difference take a look at the Iran
players this afternoon refusing to sing
their national anthem
[Music]
is what real courage looks like they did
that quite deliberately to show support
for the women of Iran back home who are
being oppressed and persecuted and
killed no virtue signaling no empty
gestures no armbands just silence and
booze from their supporters in support
of that silence That's What I Call
meaningful protests not capitulating on
your supposed moral stance because
somebody threatens to wave a yellow card
at you
I generally think fans are pretty fed up
with all the politics now this world cup
there's no doubt the FIFA's decision to
take it to Qatar was scandalous as it
was to give it to Russia at the same
time that decision was made 12 years ago
today's massive England win I hope will
Mark a turning point not just for the
England team's stuttering form and also
for the tournament itself this is the
World Cup can we please enjoy the
football
well joining me now is former England
Gokey but he played at three World Cups
Peter Shield he's also championing the
World Cup's Gambler where's the campaign
I'm excited him his former Liverpool and
Ireland International Mark Lawrence and
former football manager Harry redknapper
a veritable Trilogy of football legends
before me before I get into this debate
I want to play a clip this is from Roy
Keane today on ITV about the armband Rao
in which he made his normal forthright
views
the players could have done it for the
first game
took the punishment whatever that might
be okay and obviously you're risking
saying if he's going to get a yellow
card if that was going to be the
punishment but that would have been a
great statement do it for the first game
if you get your yellow card what a
message that would have been from Kane
or bail take your medicine and then the
next game you move on you don't wear it
because obviously again you'd want to be
getting suspended but I think it was a
big mistake I think
board players particularly obviously
that we're talking about Wales in
England here should have stopped at our
guns and done it whatever pressure from
outside and from their own associations
have the belief that's what you believe
then go with it I gotta say I completely
agree with him I mean let's start with
you Mark I mean they got themselves into
a hell of a mess here haven't they the
fa if you're going to Virtue signal for
one of a better phrase if you're gonna
show your virtue for something on a
global stage just do it then just do it
yeah don't say you're gonna do it as a
as a stand and that's why you're not
boycotting it and then bottle it well it
ended up being a come down but the other
thing as well is is and you mentioned
this about the Iranian players look they
they could well go home and end up in
prison or dead or or absolutely totally
100 dead I mean that that is a statement
yes in itself so it's just a strange one
I mean it's just it's just a small badge
I say it means a lot but a small badge
on your arm one love wear it so you get
a yellow card you know what FIFA like
FIFA would then change Minds wouldn't
they if if everybody
absolutely pathetic in this tournament
well infantino's speech of the day I
mean she's rambling nonsense and
insulting and all the rest of it unlike
this program thank you certainly not
tonight uh Peter what are you making
this because did you ever do any
protests when you were a World Cup
player for England no not at all I
personally I think all the protests
should be done before this tournament
you know I think it's it's the
tournament the World Cup is the greatest
football show that we have and I think
you know it's getting sidestepped a
little bit with with protests of this
and protests of that I just think look
let's do the protesting before and when
we get on the football pitch let's
concentrate on football you know I don't
think players should be asked to you
know
um to to do the things we're asking them
to do you know the problem is I think
some of the players want to do it
they've all got quite moral you know
moral yeah but we're political in the
last few years definitely see an upside
to Leading issues to become uh political
right I I just I think football's
football politics and politics the the
problem was that Qatar was given the
World Cup in the first place because the
FIFA should have known that there was
going to be a lot of uh protesting
against certain things have you said
that look
on that I mean Mark I I feel quite
strongly about this there's never been a
World Cup in the Middle East which is a
fantastic football loving continent
isn't it I mean we've known so many
great countries there love their
football they've never had a World Cup
they're perfectly entitled to have one
they've got issues with some of their
laws and cultures which we find
objectionable fire but what happens at
the next World Cup which is going to be
in America and Mexico and Canada right
you don't think Mexico has issues we
should be concerned about America has
Draconian laws about abortion for
example it has laws about gun rights
which we find objectionable over here in
the UK are we going to have the same
pontificating there the same protests
are we going to have monologues from
presenters no I don't think it'll be as
bad
well I mean the the thing is with this
is that for some reason it's like we're
saying that the qataris are just you
know are they lower than us yeah because
you know the Arab states Etc which
obviously no but I think the problem is
is enter lined insofar as is we think
about the organization
um you know such a small country all
those kind of things the other thing is
wealthiest is as we all know that you
know FIFA's corrupt anyway well that's
the problem has been for years and years
and years and until you sort them out
it's a waste of time what about the BBC
here being it seems to me morally
selective they're happy to plan
yeah you know they do it at China but
they don't do it here strange strange
decision now I would imagine and I
wouldn't know but I wouldn't imagine
that would have come from the very very
top right BBC it's a very deliberate
decision if you are if you are living in
the Middle East if you're an Arab
football fan and you're watching the
discrepancy between the way you're being
treated on these things compared to
Russia and China you're not going to be
very happy about it we wouldn't be you'd
be raving math right yeah I mean we
shouldn't we shouldn't be going down
this road really I mean we should be
talking about England's Great win they
were great weren't they and not Harry
Kane yeah wearing an armband I mean like
I said you know protesting is fine you
know do it before the tournament get it
out the way but once you get on that
pitch you know it's Level Playing Field
and and well let me talk to you to Harry
redknapp Harry what do you make of all
this they've got themselves into a right
dog's dinner it seems to me
absolutely appears and and like the lads
are saying like Peter just said there
I'm you know I think we're all getting
it's non-stop you know the World Cup
really is all we hear about it's not the
football it's about do we take the need
do we wear the armband it's just
non-stop let's we look back a few years
you know we got stopped from wearing a
poppy on our shirt you know and England
weren't allowed to wear the poppy uh
around you know and we stand for it uh I
think we end up did we wear it on our
short or white shorts or so there was a
change of whatever it's just you know
I don't know we've gone out there to
play This World Cup there's a million
problems going on
everything's you know not right what
they're up to I uh you know uh and
something has to be done about it
obviously if we feel that strong then
Harry Kane would say we're gonna we
should have worn the armbanders I think
as Roy Keane said take the yellow card
today and get on with it Gareth Bell
take the yellow if you bleed that
strongly well you know what if you're
gonna make a sense
if we're really that morally outraged
don't go right you know we people have
boycott the World Cup boycott Olympics
if you feel that strong absolutely but I
would say to to England fans don't get
on their high horse about guitar we did
illegally invade Iraq for example yeah
only a few years ago right we sparked
two decades of Isis terrorism with our
illegal invasion of that country there
are lots of people in the Middle East
have a pretty dim view of what we did uh
and we've never been held accountable no
one have a boycotted England and asked
supporting events because of it and I
think if you are living in the Middle
East looking at that again you think
double standards but Harry let me turn
to happier things England looked
terrific today yeah I was particularly
pleased it looks like Arsenal we're
going to win the World Cup through the
kyosaka
they listen when you look at our Squad
page you look at the lads who came off
the bench that's what I thought yeah
fantastic
players and you suddenly you're looking
at I watched a Holland team they
couldn't live with us I mean you look at
their players that you know they've got
two or three fantastic players you know
Van Dyke one a couple of great players
but after that they've got a lot of
average players who have been to England
and never cracked it and are really not
good enough to play at the top level
here we've we've got a real opportunity
I think you know I think we've got some
incredible players especially forward
Bellingham yeah what a young player 19
years of age sacker looks fantastic even
the subs have come off the bench today
rashford came on off the benches Squad
of Grace
we're all going overboard though yeah
so you're going to the game right oh
they were shocking yeah you're expecting
them to win yeah do you expect them to
score six no do you expect them to
consider a couple of goals no so I think
with England you are where you are you
you've been in a World Cup three times
but I still think I still think we've
got I still think we've got a good group
of players
your first game like that I mean I
remember lots of World Cups where we've
got off to a rugby start we've expected
to win when you have a thumping win like
that and you look so good it does send a
message to everybody else I've got
American friends obviously the big game
on Friday USV England and they're
they're worried they're looking at Oscar
wow you look good yeah well that's a
good thing to put a bit of fear into
people but I think it was the way we
played and the quality of the goals you
know it wasn't that we were given a lot
of the goals we we actually it was great
moves great football and and that was
good I mean um but you know you've just
gotta put that to the back of your mind
because uh the game against the USA
could be totally different you know USA
look good tonight as well my biggest
problem with with the England team is
it's just at the back you know I think
we just we we've not looked solid I mean
we've let in two goals again I know we
scored six that would just be my fear
but the creative players but looks you
know he looks colossal doesn't it I
think we're more sacker in this room
yeah
one of us is I want to bring in uh
Arena tonight this is the first time
we've done this a live audience of real
football fans joining us there they all
are I want to go I want to get to all of
you uh but you're all part of it
obviously I want to start with Mark
Disney now Mark where are you
okay I see you now Mark you're not going
to watch the World Cup at all why
he's been silenced yeah I think I'm a
bit more honest than to watch the World
Cup which is
um
completely trashed by contracts
corruption you can't ignore six and a
half thousand people buried under the
stadiums they're playing in and that's
just a simple fact but they choose to
and they say we have to do it for
contractual reasons
I was asked to comment about the arm bad
now the armband's a very simple thing it
was a simple protest which is globally
supported and he would have just won an
arm bad and so what it wouldn't have
changed anything but they would have
made their feelings known like the
Iranians did and yeah they will probably
disappear for it right they wouldn't
have done
on the migrant workers what I would say
on that is there's a lot of dispute
about exactly how many have died it's
clearly reprehensible if even one has
but the figure of six and a half
thousand may include a lot of people who
just died anyway in that 10-year process
but not from the conditions they were
working we don't actually know the exact
number that's not to hide it or to
defend any of it clearly a lot of people
have died in the process of putting on
these these uh This World Cup however
the number is disputed and we don't
actually know which is part of the
problem uh let me bring in now uh slim
Williamson well sorry make your points
quickly the the problem is if they want
to come up with a more credible number
of people that have died then do so yeah
but to say most of them have died
because of heart attacks yeah no I agree
credulity I agree with you let me bring
in slim Williamson uh you think there's
a lot of hypocrisy here Slim
yeah there's definitely a lot of
hypocrisy going on I mean
which country is without not without
issues at the moment you know I mean
ourselves included so if you're gonna
speak on qatar's issues then you have to
speak on everyone else's issues and then
if you're not going to have a World Cup
in Qatar then where are you going to
have it well that's my problem where is
actually clean enough where is morally
pure enough right because one of the
things about Qatar is that the it's
illegal to be gay in Qatar it's illegal
to be gay in eight of the 32 countries
left in the World Cup right including
most of Africa so you can never have a
World Cup in Africa right so where do
you have it you have it in America I've
just explained they've got issues with
their laws there Mexico has huge
problems with human rights you know I
just don't know once you put the moral
Halo on I'm not sure where it stops that
is pure enough to satisfy the critics
yeah I agree 100 with you and I feel
like
Us in this country we're very uh we pick
what we want to be outraged at so yeah
we want to be outraged that you know
Qatar but then there'll be something
else and we'll just turn a bland eye to
that so yeah it stinks very much of
hypocrisy to me yeah I'm with you I want
to bring in Zach bookbinder you think
the guitar has the right to ban the one
love armbands tell me why
well Hugo Louise he made a great point I
thought where players coming into their
country should respect their laws and I
think it's the same with the alcohol if
they don't want to provide alcohol
that's not a problem and if they're
against obviously the lgbtq community I
think it's just right to respect their
laws that's what I believe yeah yeah and
I think on the bear point I mean it's
it's not like we exactly showered
ourselves in glory at the Euro finals is
it when I was there it was absolutely
disgusting a bunch of coat snorting
Booth swelling brawling imbeciles with
no tickets spreading kovid and beating
everyone up they can get their hands on
that's not the greatest advert of having
beer around stadiums so sorry
to any England fans offended by that but
I was there and it was horrible yeah
[Laughter]
um just finally for this part of the of
the fan Zone as we're calling it uh
Harry simu simu
um there shouldn't be an issue with
England wearing the armbands you don't
think but you have got mixed feelings
about it tell me why
I guess for me I think that the problem
really is with FIFA um you know I think
what they've done is they've put the the
teams in a position whereby they're at a
sporting disadvantage if they wear it
the yellow card thing can have a
knock-on effect and have an impact later
on in the tournament I know people have
said Roy Keane included that you should
just wear it and and you know get on
with it and sort of take the
consequences and I get that a protest
without consequences not as powerful so
I totally understand that but I think
instead of sort of looking at the the
two teams and the decisions they've
taken I think we should be looking at
the fact that FIFA have made a move to
put these two sides at a sporting
disadvantage if they actually follow
through with this and that's the problem
rather than sort of England or Wales
well as we've been talking a US
journalist says he was briefly detained
on Monday trying to enter a World Cup
stadium in Qatar while wearing a rainbow
shirt Grant Ward a former Sports
Illustrated journalist so he was denied
entry and he was asked to take his shirt
off so there's a lot of stuff going on
here a lot of attempts to suppress The
Virtue signaling we'll discuss more of
this later on but also discuss of course
my interview with Cristiano Ronaldo
which has more to put it mildly it's got
everybody going uh and he's probably got
Cristiano Ronaldo going from Manchester
United so we're going to debate after
debris including a debate with Kevin
Peterson who of course was England
cricketer who was drummed out of the
England team in not for similar
circumstances where respect played a
major part I think in that decision
making we'll talk to Kevin Metz
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back to Facebook uncensored
a staggering 60 million people have now
viewed my interview because John Ronaldo
online 15 million of I watched the whole
thing 45 million have watched all the
clips extraordinary numbers an
extraordinary iconic sports with you
today passed 500 million followers on
Instagram to put it in context the next
highest person followed on Instagram is
Lionel Messi his great rival 124 million
fewer followers so he's got 25 percent
more followers on Instagram than anyone
else alive quite extraordinary well the
explosive interview touched on Ronaldo's
family and the ill treatment he feels he
suffered at the hands of Manchester
United let's remind you of some of the
highlights from the interview
I'm trying to force you out yes not only
the coach but the other two or three
guys there around
the club
at the senior executive level yes that I
felt betrayed
I don't know what's going on but since
since the Sarah likes Ferguson left I
saw not evolution in the club the
progress was Zero the glazes they don't
they don't care about about the club the
empathy with the coach is not good I'm
I'm honest you don't have a good
relationship
I'm not mean good relationship you think
he respects you
I think you don't you don't respect the
way I should deserve you must be worried
sick I mean you I was very worried baby
son and now your baby daughter's in
hospital exactly kind of that didn't
believe
that something going wrong which is this
make me feel bad really yes I am yes I
didn't believe you they believe you but
in the same way they are their peace
ever gonna change
the health of my family
for a football never
[Music]
well extraordinary stuff and it's made
headlines of course around the entire
world I've never had so many calls and
texts and messages and emails asking for
interviews or just commenting
um this morning in his first public
appearance since the interview Cristiano
said he won't be silenced
in my life the best timing is always my
timing obviously on your side it's easy
to give an opinion it's easy to write
many times the truth many lies about me
the best timing is always my timing well
we can all have our view about how
Cristiano Ronaldo might be feeling why
he did this but sometimes the best
people to ask are those who've been in
The Cauldron of high level sport Kevin
Peterson is for me the best thing in The
Bachelor of the generation was
International career for England was cut
short after high profile Fallout with
his employers the ECB and he joins Me
Now Kevin great to see you when you when
you watched it what did you make of
Ronaldo's mindset why he did this what
may have been behind it
I think he's at the end of his tether
um I think if you read the reports and
you you see why he's been in the news
and how many times he's been in the news
for all the wrong reasons by him but all
the right reasons by clearly his
employees and
these things happen
two people for reasons that they don't
want
and it's when I was watching I mean I
just got back from Dubai yesterday and I
got up every morning and I just watched
it I was one of your 15 million that was
the full interview I didn't watch you I
watched him peers and it was it was it
was incredibly
it was incredibly enlightening because
you can sort of see a similar position
to what I had now not for any stretch of
the imagination am I sitting here saying
that I'm as famous as Cristiano Ronaldo
because it's absolutely not true you've
just talked about how famous he is
but what you could see is that actually
he's very unhappy in a place that he
should be happy and feels disrespected
well forget disrespect I hate the word
disrespect there are two places when you
are in The Cauldron and you are top lead
at the top athletes and you're right at
the top of your game where you should
feel happy you should feel comfortable
and you should be able to do whatever
you want because that's where you should
be free that's at home with your family
and the second place is at the training
ground you can see he's unhappy at the
training ground now I know that
Carrington and I think it's called
Carrington where man united trains their
facility isn't up to scratch no have a
look at his social media and look where
he trains look how he practices to be
the best you have to
live the best life and to be the best
you have to continually need to grow and
we all talk about being that high level
athlete it's that extra one percent what
is it like I remember this with you when
you were going through your problems
with England we spoke a lot over that
time and the thing that really incends
to you is all this drip drip drip of
stuff that was coming out about you most
of which I knew wasn't true because you
were telling me the reality Cristiano
the same thing it's a constant drip drip
drip of negative stories about him 95 of
which he says are completely untrue I've
been talking to him regularly for six
months yeah through this process and I I
know when I fact check these things in
real time he said it's not true it's not
true it's not true all one is true or
whatever
you're overriding negative well you know
you've been editor of newspapers you've
been in the media there are stories that
get drip fed to journalists yes about
certain people who want to know them who
want to knife certain athletes and one
thing I hate is their tall puppy
syndrome I mean why can't he be
celebrated here I mean I was in Dubai
and I got back yesterday and no one can
bill believe how this country are going
after Cristiano Ronaldo yeah they cannot
believe it the people in the airports in
in hotels everybody Lives why on Earth
are people going at him I mean he is
such a proven performer but you can see
his frustration and you can and you can
identify the issues he goes back to a
facility that's not up to scratch he
goes to a facility where he wants to be
the best where he wants to maintain
standards you say you don't like the
word disrespect I mean he used that a
lot because he feels that if you're not
respected for what you've achieved in
the game and he still believes he has
lots of obvious super fit as you know
you were very fit actually when you left
the England so you could have played
another five six years he thinks he's
got another two or three years at least
he felt it was just a disrespect from
everyone there that had decision-making
power yeah well I I think that he is at
that level where he commands respect
because of what he's achieved in the
game I do I agree with you I think he's
the greatest footballer that's played
the game he's he he he he turns the
needle that's what he does and there's a
reason and why he's still making
headlines four or five days after the
interview because of who he is there's
not many athletes in the world that can
do that all right and so there's a
reason also why he's in that position
because of the way that he practices
because of the way that he lives his
life because of the sacrifices that he's
had to make as an individual to achieve
what he's achieved you understand that I
know that you you know for all your
obvious many thoughts uh not as many as
you but for all your money Falls uh
everyone we've got one big fault we've
chosen you but even if your colleagues
you know had a problem with you
personally whatever they all said the
same thing you were the first in a last
letter training Ronaldo the same you
never hear anything about his training
regime he's unbelievably self-driven and
you had that as well whilst having this
polarizing reputation of it do you
relate to him on that level I I think
it's it's those one presenters and and
to be the best you you have to tick
every single box and I and I'll go back
to it you have to be happy at home where
he is
um but where he also hasn't been over
the last six months I mean your own
you're as a parent you're only as happy
as you unhappiest child right and I he
went through totally exactly right
exactly right and and you know what if
what he said is true about them not
believing what's been happening with
this family and I can't say whether it's
true or not he says it is true
that's almost unforgivable yeah because
he's a human at the end of the day yes
he's super famous yes he's worth
hundreds of millions of dollars he's
achieved that because he's amazing at
what he does he plays what do you think
of the particular point he made on the
field when ten hogged the new coach
doesn't bring him on against Manchester
City and says he did side of respect and
then the next game they're winning
easily against Tottenham and he wants to
bring him on with three minutes to go
completely contradicting what he'd said
the week before
I think and and my foot more knowledge
isn't amazing but I think there was a
quote from ten Hogg talking about the
fact that he was the fourth in line to
Captain United a couple of days or a
couple of games after
um his issue where he walked off the
field it's something that even if you
think it as a coach you don't say it in
public and that's what I can't
understand now that's why I actually
agree with everything that Cristiano has
said purely based on the fact that no
coach if he cares about his player would
do that I agree Mourinho why was
Mourinho amazing why did Lampard Terry
drug but all these guys I mean I did all
my rehab for my achilles at uh um uh
Cobham at Chelsea's training ground why
do they love Mourinho if the team had a
bad game Mourinho made the game about
itself venue was the same all the great
managers I think protect their players
but if I take the players okay please
stay here we're gonna come back get more
from you and from my virtual audience
all watching here so I'm shaking the age
and derision oh there's nodding agreeing
this is certainly dividing people so
we'll debate the Ronaldo interviewing
The Fallout after the break
well welcome back to Piers Morgan
uncensor before the break we heard from
cricket Legend Kevin Peterson and
sympathy for Cristiano Ronaldo's
position at Manchester United can't be
still with me as his former Liverpool
Legend Mark lawrenson along with Chief
sports reporter for the Times Martin
Ziegler so Martin let me go to you
um you're not as supportive of Cristiano
Ronaldo in fact quite the opposite why
well I mean that this isn't about um
your your great scoop peers I mean which
was obviously the an excellent get
um but it's it's the the the reason why
Cristiano Ronaldo did this
um and what's happened as a result and I
believe he's lost tarnished his legacy
with the Manchester United supporters
um this was somebody who was a hero for
for many many years and people
absolutely loved him all the Manchester
United fans now a lot of people a lot of
the fans I think are really really
unhappy
um he talked about betrayal I think they
feel betrayed well they might but
football fans are very very fickle
aren't they because they're all sucking
up to Ronaldo when he scored 24 goals
last season and was banging in hat
tricks it was player of the season and
so on uh you know they're all chanting
Viva Ronaldo he's only started four
games this season and they've already
got on his back and they've done it
because the media's been very negative
and he believes a lot of that's been
driven by people at the club who have a
problem with him so I think it's these
things can be you know the fans can be
sold online about a player I saw this
Arsenal with a bamier which I thought he
was also treated very unfairly
um they can buy into a narrative which
may not be true and I I think that may
have happened with Ronaldo
depends what you want from your I think
what you want to when your career ends
and when you look back do you want to
think I I the club that made me
um do I want to look back on on that
with with dignity
um and with self-respect and and I I
don't think you can now um
Roy Keane is still a United Legend he
did exactly the same thing as Ronaldo he
just did it on man united TV I mean
there's no difference to me about what
he did and you talk about tarnishing
Legends I mean Maradona you know you
take all the drugs and the mafia links
and all that kind of stuff none of that
cared to his legacy and what's Ronaldo
done that's so bad he's incredibly fit
he works hard he's committed he eats
well he doesn't really drink much you
know he's in many ways he's a perfect
role model he's just finally decided to
have his say given that everybody else
has had to say about him for the last
six months and been blaming him for all
United's problems I don't really have a
problem with that
this is somebody
who's earning a huge amount of money a
huge amount of money millions and
millions of pounds yeah but you're
Martin you can't go back on money
if he wanted if
no well no obviously if he if he feels
frustrated that he's not getting a
um a fair show well go to Manchester
United and say you know I I I will you
do not have to pay me for the rest of my
contract I you know I'm worth 500
million I really don't think it's about
money I mean bring him right Lawrence I
don't think money is the issue with
money he's got half a billion he is I
think we're missing the point here that
this is a story about a footballer who's
been a brilliant footballer I think we'd
all agree with that absolutely totally
but he's dealing with the fact that it
he's not got the same strengths that
he's had you can't do the same things
that he's had and consequently in his
head he still feels that he can he
admitted the car interview he admitted
that mind to me he's not the same as he
was but what he said was he was he did
score 24 goals last season it's called
one more Premier League goal than Harry
Kane who was lorded as one of the best
strikers in the world so he he may have
diminished the powers by his own
standards but actually by the standards
of the Premier League last season he was
right up there
this scene's another season no but but
when you're 37 you know eventually it's
like you stop but and what's happened to
him off the field the fact that he lost
he lost a child and then his daughter
that survived the tragedy had a weak in
hospital he was incredibly worried about
that that's why he didn't go back to
preseason put all that together this has
all happened in the space gone but why
so right so you're you're 10 how you're
the manager right and with all with all
these capabilities that Ronaldo Hado has
whichever way you want to look at it why
wouldn't you play him this this guy sees
him every single day in training and
he's made this decision which is you're
not gonna play right but if you're not
gonna play him still treat him with
respect and have sympathy for him and
look after him treat him like the legend
that he is Kevin I get that don't drip
feed to the media because that's what we
hate yeah what we hate is waking up in
the morning and seeing constant lies and
I don't buy the the theory about he's on
this this amount of money there's a
reason why he's on that amount of money
because he is the greatest thing it's
got nothing to do with it he is the
greatest footballer that's played the
game no he's not messy is but there you
go uh Ronaldo is but let's go back to
Martin you'll be listening patiently
Martin
um I I genuinely don't think the money
has gotten to do with Ronaldo's thingy
because he's got so much of it I think
you know he's quite happy not to get any
more money from United I think what he
wants he wants respect and he wants to
go somewhere where he feels he'll get
properly valued and his assessment of
his abilities right now is that he's
lost none of his ability from last
season he's just not been given the same
chances
well he he talks a lot about respect
isn't he but I don't think Cristiano
Ronaldo is treating people with respect
I think that he he believes he should
start you know he if he won't come off
the subs bench because he thinks it's uh
it's beneath his dignity he leaves the
match early that sort of behavior is not
the behavior of the best player well he
apologized for that over there he
apologizes that in the interview and he
apologized to his teammates but he
didn't apologize to ten ha because the
week before ten Hogg hadn't brought him
on because he said he respected him too
much and then the next week he wants to
bring him on with three minutes left
when they're winning two nil why is that
not disrespectful if you yourself have
said you didn't bring him on the way
before out of respect
well I just think you you've got to Rise
Above This as a player you can't have
your your own sort of it seems to me a
sort of petty squibble about whether
you're coming on for just do it for the
team don't think about yourself all the
time I know he's had really awful
personal problems and it's very
absolutely people should be putting an
arm around it and helping him but when
it comes to those moments on the field
of play just do it for the team okay
where do you think he goes Pierce I
think he goes to another big Club I
think he'll have a good World Cup yeah
really I think he's gonna be a good
World Cup and surprise you
I do I absolutely team yeah okay Bridges
just down the road Ronaldo's weekly
salary he goes to a Champions League
team no you're all right
breaking news Gareth Bale has equalized
for Wales wow against team us the 82nd
minute with a penalty it's a good news
there let's go back to the Morgan Arena
I want to bring in a Theo Delaney you
think uh Cristiano has an over-inflated
sensitivism own importance why
well it's clear isn't it it's a team
game and and football's full of uh
players who think they should be in the
team or think they shouldn't be uh you
know taken off or brought on or benched
or whatever and he thinks that he
shouldn't be uh playing under those
conditions he thinks he should be
treated especially and I understand why
like you say he's got more social media
followers than anyone else on Earth you
know he's got more money than any other
footballer probably possibly barring
Messi you know he's rightly admired for
being one of the greatest players of all
time but at the end of the day it's a
team game and the manager has to make
those decisions all the other players
who are struggling with these things
week in week out and they're in every
Club yeah but they don't I think to be
fairly Cristiano Ronaldo they don't have
the same pressures or responsibilities
that come with being the goat uh
let me bringing Jonathan kid um you
think ten Hogg the manager should have
communicated better with Ronaldo
I think he's been forced to engineer
this move now hasn't he Ronaldo because
he should really be playing every game
you've scored 24 the year before
obviously we don't know what's going on
on the training ground but uh
um uh I think you should build the team
around Ronaldo in the same way that
Chelsea have managed with Thiago Silva
to keep him going because he's uh even
though he's 37 he's Fitness personified
and I think that uh I think they should
be making a place for Ronaldo he's one
of the best footballers in the world
yeah and I just don't get this and I can
see why he I think he's engineered this
move yeah I completely I completely
agree with that
ten Hogg sees him every day in training
he does yeah right so don't you think
tenorg just got them the difference
well wait a minute she's a very unproven
manager never won anything outside of
Holland so far right right but if at the
end of the season for example without
Ronaldo United end up six or seventh
yeah they haven't won the Europa League
then you're judging but what I'm saying
is so their thought right so ten hog has
got to win games if he thought that
Ronaldo could play every week and score
every week and win games he'd play you
know what if I know no no you know what
you do if you're 10 hog you lie to the
media and keep telling the media how
much you love him and how you'll start
him that is what you do to players of
his quality yeah you look after him you
protect him you put your arm around him
and you love him let me bring in uh
Daisy yeah you think Cristiano thinks
he's bigger than the club I mean he's
got I think 20 times as many Instagram
followers
some players that's the odd bigger than
clubs right I mean Ronaldo is the
biggest football star in the world
of the messy I just think I think
the honest with you pierce I think and
the rest of the panel I think the one
thing we haven't discussed at all which
I think is the most important thing is
it's about the football
and it's about which style of football
the manager wants to play now last year
when he was signed by solskar there was
a certain style of football maybe
solskyo believed that Ronaldo fitted to
that style ten Hogg wants to play a
different style of football he wants to
play high pressing very very energetic
football and Ronaldo is 67. it's as
simple as that and and he's been a
footballer 67 he's not loud
and it's very good for 67. I can tell
you that
good good point
manager changes you're liable to have a
change of style they should have let him
go in the summer then accept it uh final
word to you guys what do you think
happens with Ronaldo now Mark it goes
where to
um no one in the Champions League really
it might go to Saudi to your mate in
Saudi he's already turned down 250
million can you imagine how many 350
million Euros
which I know from the guy who made the
offer would you would you turn down 305
million uh
why would you offer him 350 million
pounds for goodness uh because actually
in Saudi Arabia they think he's like a a
sporting God and he would transform him
I don't think he'd enjoyed playing at
that level he wants to play top level I
admire the hunger of a guy with half a
billion in the bank who's 37 years old
who still wants to kick it at the
highest level listen I get it but I'm
afraid at that level right no no don't
leave it there guys thank you Kevin Mark
great to see you and thank you to Martin
really appreciate it uh next I'm talking
about my pack at least one of whom I
think knows a bit about football not
quite as convinced by the other two but
we're about to find out
foreign
I've got eight million Twitter followers
and nearly two million Instagram how are
you guys doing uh just just a bit under
that
having gone to 500
and followers on Instagram that is a
level of stardom and fame you can't even
imagine there's only eight billion
people in the world and that includes
people in India and China who may not
have access to in Instagram one in 16 of
the world is following him what do you
make of the Ronaldo interview The
Fallout everything
you know what I love is he's spoken out
yes and I'm sick and tired as a football
fan of being told a player is ill or
injured and you know there's a bit
there's a big uh falling out and he's
he's honest about it I mean man united
have to deal with it and what do you
think yeah I mean it's massive it's
probably the best interview of the year
but you know that yeah
but you know I think it revealed so much
about him that I mean my opinion is
slightly different to yours I think kind
of shows a man who's getting a little
bit on in the career and he sort of
knows but he's aware of that he said
that an interview sure but I thought it
was so fascinating to see someone that
raw I thought you brought that out of
him actually I mean I was laughing with
him afterwards because of course I had
my little bus stop at Good Morning
Britain and I knew what he meant it's
like when you feel disrespect yeah
sometimes you just gotta you gotta go
with your guts see I'm not having it
you've got to be in a position to be
able to do that yes and uh which he
clearly is I mean I agree with that and
you were and that's a strength but
there's always two sides to a story and
I would like somebody from Manchester
United or they'd be deafening so far in
their silence yeah I'm not really
denying anything he said I mean I mean
it's an interesting thing isn't it if
you just take it to the employment level
you've got this massive figure who's now
basically taken on his employer but the
thing is as a lifelong United fan he's
not saying anything that we haven't the
club the supporters of the club haven't
been saying for years I mean even as
Zlatan said something similar we always
knew Pogba wasn't very happy towards his
latter Mourinho said it exactly and he's
just confirming what the fans knew I
think my respect for him has gone
through the roof because it's clear he
never did any of this is his legacy
United tongues he could be tying his
shoelaces for the next 20 years in his
legacy that's what I think I think it's
a ridiculous disease tarnish I mean Roy
Keane is beloved and he fell out just as
spectacularly let's move to Virtue
signaling you and I would use a
different phrases for this yeah but did
this what happened today with the
armband exactly what I feared which is
once you start doing this kind of thing
if you don't then follow through and you
say that we're going we're going to make
our stand there and then you bottle it
when you're threatened with a yellow
card the whole thing looks like an
insincere sham look I'm not a big fan of
arm bands with with statements but I
think the you know the people who come
out of this badly FIFA because they've
sold the World Cup too instead of the
players one of those places
they have sold it to a vile regime I've
beaten the Qatar twice to go the layback
yeah I saw the exploitation of workers
treated appallingly but you would say
that about anywhere in the Middle East
right uh so what better than others but
the thing is where would you allow World
Cup to take place in the Middle East
well actually Egypt although it's got a
very cool human rights
that's when you lose me how can you
possibly say Egypt that's better human
rights because it does but I wouldn't
know but no I argue I argue Egypt
because it's a football a nation right
okay
bring it down a little bit so I really
agree with your point where you were
talking about virtue signaling but what
I didn't like today was we were talking
about LGBT and we were talking about how
it's not quite right with their culture
being gay is not a culture it's not a
life I agree well that's just your
existence eight of the last 32 teams of
a tournament Outlaw homosexual fine but
I think you can appreciate you can
appreciate that during that game today
the Iranians looked incredibly Brave in
front of our team who wouldn't even wear
a silly little armbank I'm sorry I I
actually take a completely different
view I think it's completely
disrespectful to wear that I'm not going
to come into your house no I'm serious
you do not go to someone else's country
and flagrantly disrespect their culture
I'm not I'm never going to come into
your house
hold on but I would never come to your
house and start jumping on your bed with
you with my shoes on because I respect
you and your home you don't go to
someone else because shoes on is very
different
I agree with you I agree with you but
what happens when we go to America given
their laws on abortion exactly are we
going to have the same moralizing by the
BBC the same monologue yes
but that's silly because the US and UK
have an equally pressuring relationship
and we should be pressurizing those
states in the US to leave we shouldn't
be pressurizing anyone
let's end on a happiness are we going to
win the World Cup after today's
exhilarating 62 picture no
get me out soon I I doubt it there's a
lot of you know what I actually think
you didn't have a chance I I feel very
encouraged by that today mainly because
the best player was because
Arsenal are going to win the world
that's it for me thank you my virtual
audience you were great sorry didn't get
to all of you whatever you're up to Keep
It Uncensored and come on England
tonight
[Music]